good evening counselors our officers
thank you for coming
special weapons like to to buy quarter
after the first automation figure out
the executives red for the emergency
evacuation out so those are no public
yet
apologies for absence
[Music]
substitute ministers my plan
November spitting sound
normative in the very
it's very much Vincent amazing hold on
some remarks everybody in the group they
read the river
so crazy
the
receive decorations interest
and again I can we have the Excel this
is report please
okay in relation to the external support
eventually provide a status update in
relation to the recommendations made
works but in order the dryest
recommendations release the preparations
of finances things I've had been a draft
of what we address going forward
recommendation five relates to the
absence of an effective internal
registers which is now been attracted in
2015 17 seafood effective provided by
County Council at the 2015 theme we are
making battlin Council under a 3d
agreement and results the next three
years we have any specific issues around
recommendations happy to take back
thank you a lot of the items and
recommendations here were originally for
timing to be complete by the end of
March move forward to the end of May and
we have passed into May and you tell us
if they are now complete yeah no problem
yep the original intention was to get
our counter pose because we consume are
seven things here active weather next
year the timetable has been compressed
and simulates an issue of the experience
we've been fairly successful we have
been our marks they're lining up quite
ambitious and we are predominately well
what at the end of mania must be
complain and we'll be in this week by
only should be getting that offset
attention we are sorry I've overly
everything feeling
so what I do is are we still waiting to
compare
that one yet one two three six seven
so you say that we finished all of them
by the end of this week to name yet
responsible yep national enable that
done yes
magically working papers will be what
has been a pretty endless
financial statement reasons closing
balances in our surviving so that's
that's our complete you won't eat
anything till we're going to producing a
couple in time but yes I will be ready
way in the week and then in terms of the
Mr P it done as well definitely and
seven plus patient reasons in our
village investor so everything will be
not going this week unless of course to
us yet we don't
so going forward date the new sequences
as a driver for local person said yes
did you see any problems are going to
Berkeley team not Adam Captain Obvious
kind of heart I'm going to issues next
is we are not the only local
let's press the moment and how they 99%
what we put in places that we had hired
a new technical accountant we start with
a change entry of every medical year
here buying me these margins people be
fairly low-key dinner hangs evenly two
or three times over worth more the
orbiters and all I'm hoping is once you
get through in September everything we
do currently environments or thumbs up
we do it all at the end what we're
trying to do now is stop doing the full
price of specify the against an
importance now we've got someone who's
dedicated students jobs that he'll be
able to actually close the inspectors
will talk me about some context on that
we hit the New Times online yes I hope
time really works I have to do it looks
like I'll be important for their high we
might so leading on from there so with
the right if you'll sign $0.99
accountants of an ad properties and you
are admitting that we will ever grow
dyslexia what's the implication
including
can I ask you can I ask you a question
myself read my resume
[Music]
ketosis slightly changed from what we
have the order Commission used to list
the councils of things whether
accounting time but we would have to
report up with the county
case the issue is will found both sides
plus climbing deadline
there's a tracking mission we put for
that all the way forward
make sure as well and that's the we
finished our council because us this
year it helped with the with the one to
see where we anticipated we found
bottlenecks
Arnold Ronald appointments in two
variants
there is a person a group to
understanding preset
are there any punitive follow ones that
might affect council we are late
Charley's etc well in if you do in terms
I think we fought the only shared
Sebastian of seconds
servicing by the Oort Commission out of
the motivations are next year what was
the matter reporters produced locally
temple important service
police translate without exercise in
terms of what we can depend delays the
council the council courses there will
be yes
much more than some benign in China
crisis
you know the bond milking a second
probably a recognition I forgot my
sweater and yes we can see the don't buy
jewelry in class lots of apartments
which dazu they're actually the
architect behind in size in a budgetary
bulky we could be a balance about the
resources but we the best we can
first actually nice and I do
I'm absolutely guarantee there will be
over
is there a stage where clarity is done
to come the action in life is very
resistant you
but yes there would be in there they're
usually in structure in place in advance
of boson in lava I'm not aware ever is
pyramid structures clear Commission card
members announce that you survive
oxygen safely
mr. Olmstead just
car crashing the next week
everybody happy that we have any other
you will
recommended for recommendations that
pretty result which is a place to
identity and acknowledgement we respect
ourselves protect emoji supreme
types of seventh-annual distance to the
patient the
in
I check confidence
I just give a brief summary reports the
house alleges to inform the committee
and defeat of 2013
the thief covered the two items these
are made from this building work you
could be nicer
completion
important transaction element of these
of Education now
based on the Swiss consumption take
standpoint for
and other gals being able to accept
defeat to change the foot seven thousand
six months level one area that we may
consider actually feet regarding earlier
which is mallet
it's amazing and
bezel-set throughout fits around your
quarters who
good stuff
have not yes at the fees that have been
on the website there and the storm
so where we bring all this licenses
gypsy and obviously by January next year
one of the
the world day
just a magical crystal it'll be peaceful
Green penguin or root pence for love
arrest about mating this is just a
progression that that's not for me
for animal consumption you all know you
prefer tall these things
[Music]
what will happen to being the council
Green Day way in solar activity three
accounts of the council of property
skaters I think after the consolidation
process counts
Tolman
I knew I came from a sustained
salvation
not fully
so
you can't escape
together
the
most interchangeably Janette don't use
the musical numbers I think best I can
use moment little fox years ago hosting
young which due to subsidence in air and
in once that finishes we are at the end
of that illness that's a national
internet every local authority and then
go out to or transport what
lots of the socials do enjoy some of the
PSA I
and what they do improve to get us an AB
security of apartment yes I I that we
get a bill and that we seriously
we've said the other young for 14 years
and after that we might have someone
that
that's something we are quite lucky week
with back back see on whatever we want
sinus like every other local authorities
they have a projector
on the other
the recommendation s if a person becomes
an ally audience occupation please
17:18 yet to be noticed so free
my tomates internal audience value
report
there are four behind the some of the
worst eternal it sees the 2015 17
appendix one for I felt we were clear
under painting it should be noted that
for 2050 some seen an uptick plans
reduced approved by the city back into
mountain in June 2015
something mother's line placement
previous year the work of the would
extremes designed in such a way to make
an individual on the April adequately
and effectiveness of the council
controlled environment by that I mean to
regions of governance risk management
and internal control the 2015 15 my
opinions on that reassurance in a state
he astounded them in firm control but
there are areas for improvement
I recognize the counter failure is an
area absolutely monthly get scripts
weapons new year and we looked on the
paper for risk assessments like that
define the areas of the council
vulnerable to fraud and understand more
controls we have been placed when we do
gain such fruit
in terms of the effectiveness of
internal audit Department this could be
sees compliance with the public set
return or defenders washers can actually
achievable effective and it's projection
annually planned the 2015 17 and again
for 2017 18
first a peer review was under thinking
of the order function glasses countdown
to a matching plan to be put in place to
address any identified weaknesses
progress against an action plan provided
an appendix for
an external review Lieberman supported
function has been commissioned to 2019
something that's required for every five
years I'm quiet it's like any questions
in relation to my Angela I sort of just
announced it take your eyes checked okay
46 in area of insecurity and access
complete zero under how often is that
going to be reviewed up see doing the IT
security file yeah the plan is produced
in relation to a respect assistant with
the controlled environment so it based
on our certainty probably beyond Sega's
every year what something equals button
the risky area yet there is planet
that's were to give advice and receive
listen
it completely we will forest renovations
made
yeah that's relation speaking to clean
now 0.37 ways to do business for this
year son slept on them father's request
to do the left
in particular is quite a high point
system might touch points and
our major civility time little young
nationalized Hospital volunteer
interpretive center for anything so the
whole process is just business
[Music]
the point of item is a community
repetitive slice where this in four
years will be Waverly on all the
prophecies which is done you have done
the review on small business Waveland
where the rates went up the love is
something so I believe never went up as
a match it some people who come out some
wins mildly at a big mind of the
Chancellor he said we'll be charging 150
family which was last year
that's not meaning that I need to not be
diplomatic way I know you know
personally the sort some to be the site
specific and sorted out may have never
what is unspent to say innovation
because ventilation
yielding proposition 14 2006 intimating
the increase
divide our initiative is a disease of
different ethnic Africa
make sure items like I don't want to
like important to the way concerns where
it is it's respected and he's not
expected encounter that gives you a
subject very circle discovery in any one
year
when we come soon there's a particular
amount of attention which we're all the
way off
with rc2
with relation to that kind of
going through the pencil
is it a case that we should actually
instigate internal audits not
necessarily when they're finished but
midstream to avoid the sort of situation
that we are in at the moment
this seems to indicate when you will not
be doing that okay Lord's roll we're not
just luck insurance provider we are
engaged in insensibly
a compliance role or a critical friend
that we are involved in projects such as
the ICU project itself and we are after
advice and guidance and we do actually
fit in such matters and after advisor so
you have a predictive already for seven
years at the critical friends and view
such projects we are that we are engaged
in Arthur advised interfacing achieve
improvements or actually on the control
sticks and stones always an active
participation it's not different I've
been on one operative is us we are we
are convening gaze in touch done like
profile projects okay so if you say you
will be asked to advise but then the
information that we come across your
desk when certain lips that be exceeded
would that mean that
he will be kicking certain systems into
place as to
trying to find out why we've got
overspend on anybody
excellent times over which is for huge
implications for athletics kitchens
depends on the specifics and regulations
as well I mean I can't comment without
knowledge this is a book that but there
are obviously regulations in place that
provide for provisions in any contract
and unless the contract itself
experiences there are provisions within
that contract you know the contract
value may be a consequence women
agreeing the both markets that depends
on the nature of the contract and it's
especially helpful for the end goal
changes and debits allows you to support
rep ranges in degrees it depends with
the contract until the office and they
are taught there for you in the end goal
is change that we would be something
else we wanted his address for the unit
and why they might be an issue if the
public's not materially changed in
emotional we want to migrate to the
cloud in effect we are still migrating
to cloud the need to expect work
probably identify district of course but
now I'm also that's why the scope that
exercise behind a communal the tree
courts are that has been specified
individual contract or relationship
until then they make an assessment as
you circle made an assessment quite on
nine fact at that time they are much
likely to change by
once they've done their scope in
Interzone the things fingers of exchange
as the prize will be in conflict with a
physical condition what I'm concerned
about then is the same projects of this
type I'm saying generally if we get a
project in future the hits and I
understand is something where
immediately you will stay
I just haven't read through arthelene
and that's purely light up that's one of
my things one by one essential basic
money management approach so they asked
me this knots working between internally
and finance make some of the are clear I
suppose I'm trying to understand work
with what becomes a notice then when it
comes out of my garden goes into
internal organ that's not how it works
obviously and I've been mostly thatment
variation happens we're not just native
reports on any something that from 2002
and going you think that's on quite at
work financial management financial
student be absolutely it will very much
without because obviously inter all you
want to make sure that we've done
nothing untoward and Republican
governors said we've done so and follow
that's where we've got to be careful we
don't understand it so many times
that's very different thing for
internally too though compares financial
management I do understand that but my
concern is the hope as far as I'm aware
audit is basically to management and we
have gone from a place that's but
expectant to the place of risk
now it does that not been more'n a
little clarity of when that situation
with purpose as to what system should
come in cuisine obviously hasn't
happened in this particular case within
the ossification I am talking generally
just forgive Jeff obviously but he is
something where it does seem as though
he's got to that cross important and
it's got way beyond it before it's then
become absolute elegant as a risk but
very getting hot I'll take that on
that's part of my role while always
gonna stand the reason to say whether I
think it's worth the money the risk of
the variety to understand actually
company it would cost to be an avoid yes
we main curve box numbers nine hundred
thousand pound on project but actually
that means we've done for another five
hundred thousand over here we contact
that positioning in complete isolation
as I understand the whole thickness well
I do understand your appreciation but
that's for us for myself internal
audience from like to understand where I
say I think there's been material issue
here is internal
or equally comes along as if you think
I've been acting outside of financial
regulation scheme of delegation things
like that absolutely that's what to
oxygen jump in but just because of
project overs name you it will do that
aren't you done being making you just
returned all the time that's just not
happen
that's all like stop talking and just go
to a signifier or make the one with the
unstable place which is quality
all those items put hanging for 2060
sentence but one take 15 2016 18
practice book them where there were
issues consulting units in tone India we
can't
on top of result are now to further I
think something is happening which of
these items is 2017-19 caused a
reduction on the working mm simply
painting or baby does we ask the work
which would clearly have big time to
dance as you might seem
but they have been here right in that
they I think are exported year
we've looked to maturity of the plan or
our view of the risk of first assessment
and they both materially altered in my
opinion for 1617 little is that we would
have claims always it's also subject to
a state of flux it depends on the risk
in Lauren we must be changing in
relation to new resource to come forward
and this work will be undertaken in
relation to the areas of activity with
identify things year but basically we
add it in the round that not only do we
need to leave things completely at least
things we didn't pick up in the previous
years also beyond playing we have
capacity to deliver both ways 57 cleanup
landed and these new risky risk event by
the new year
I won't cover their positives is
reversible and this call just come back
to that time families judicata is it
importantly world
you know folks know immigrants Games's
they're authorized what works Romero
higher risk of Moreno
what a strange
Oh
Rotten testing the blank question like
that I regard the program offices quite
fundamentally new computer it's where
all of the projects are based including
projects we for each slit but you get
and
over a scene one
project had problems because of the land
project management's must be recognized
- too late
obviously the program office is very not
reliant on project management and that
means that the bridging gap is very own
predicament results of the program
office critical because we're relied
upon it to provide the results of regard
as a political I mean there are concerns
report back on the on science project
there is a performance management a to
place that report reports committee so
it's not just in the the reason of
internal would its report on the
progress or Leslie is the wrong program
so the progress of for Jaisal to get
report dynamism and we are funded solely
through next year there's ICC look at
the robust robust into the process so
yes it's something that Pratt
we would look at in a year but that just
knows like that limitless is in place to
run program offers individual project
progress is also reported as a resistor
space to look at the robustness of the
program offices are running into
problems yes which are psy psy psy
Caucasus has in the Project Lead yet
anyways if nothing we're that by
slipping we wore dresses column levy
they all has gone to mine because I do
episodes about resources its direct
result is gained
so you say that in terms of the group
results is considered sufficient and
present and the next paragraph said
thoughts is given to supplementing
operating system in house for exhaust
areas whether it's electrics penalties
or sores sack society tea or dips and
counter for which the two key areas so
he's offset the moment of solution but
when
we look at ICT for cash flow you may
have to bring people who may be more
expert areas at let's ask around and
resources are available to do that we
have we had sufficient budget to bring
an additional requirement it's like in
any authority amount that it would to
just not have its own IT would it start
I mean I work at both the parousia a
second council in the air is mighty
would it it is an area where we look
struggles to come to grips with when we
buy in an exit eight and we do this that
budget to do so
and just one other thing by my character
appearances oscillator us and we do talk
about equality and diversity against the
pedagogy of the diversity of connections
Americans
or go back to the place that's not snare
the participle
snowboy must suppose actions seem to
operably delegate to resolve this one
that's personal results are generally
ASEAN any report on a topography in
disgust me a monitor via equal I think I
mean I mean chairman there is provision
in all report templates for equality and
diversity implications the report all
that would look at that and but it's
worth maybe just re-emphasize in that
aspect of you know to you know to report
authors there will be some reports
showing but but they did their duty
others that there's a host of
implications in the draft and they'll
put non and if it's not but yeah but
he's possible that the size of people
such a penetrates the other thing we
should be being it's like they're on our
thank you here is a quick we should
actually just get that here it looked
area
very much Jocelyn from Yonkers
Thank You Monsieur this one in the last
one and peaceful community back I 20
we've had a few issues in Council or
reasonably with I think extra money to
the new contract but business continuity
is going to be extremely effective if
this the I piety actually in this
potential risk I don't see any any
relation to the I feel you've got me all
set somewhere alive miss reading into it
something that is there a it's hidden in
your at inventions surveys on
simplifying to the recommendations
I ate two four zero
I've gone through to the last year
recommendations are specifically related
relationship electromigration financials
and individualistic Wisconsin even bank
anniversaries website and also to ensure
that we've got we're in a software
system that are being hosted elsewhere
that they've got adequate budget plans
in place as well
something we have considered
one of the things I will be concerned
about find out the roosters our exempt
you tell me
not on their control
apparently an unfriendly
that's in effect
they believe also in power line because
of our culture
so as to community
- and mine I mean I think chairman that
we can perhaps report separately - you
know to members on on the nature of our
exempts up here provided because it
wouldn't the business continuity
planning
report is about various business
continuity plans included yc2
I think that the specific question that
let's let's get back to members on
around example ports and they eraser
any other questions of the
recommendations is proposed the pressure
resolves of the chief complete executive
spend on mobile accuracy perfect
effectiveness of the council systems and
government's fiscal interest of internal
from Jabba no tusen surgery
Thank You counsel item 9 a new
government statement which endowments
incessantly considering all the
assistant director in the patent so she
presented of government a tremendous
circles
and so the reports in front view in the
round is commendable we produce that
yourself that as committee and then
happy recommendations Council the
understanding of the government
governments that have worked in our
anything so previously and how we are
and how we see images it become so in
five years mostly we've been well
discussed that we have issues with our
humanity effective last year with
counsel and 2-3 years and previously we
had great was inflated our CAE whether
we produced the 80s twn in place about a
month and hadn't Queens and I have she
bought expensive in plan so he was able
to give an opinion so that was quite
significant thing for us last
so we work very obviously this year
exiting 24 human and now we're in a
position where we were then this age yes
that actually says we've now got people
for investing in place and they are
satisfied that this insufficient work
have now therefore that our government
in flight now as it just previously they
can't give everything they can tear
through every system for every number
and slavery reports as a 100% but the
samples that they do check there are
animal control they're very mindless the
report we just saw that there are humans
we still need to work on that's
perfectly acceptable uncle Morris so
that's a good thing to deny GFP there is
obviously step forward for Astro
Botsford for this year sighs we've
actually got a little bit selective that
we satisfied with the work and actually
Lords time going to the cross the report
actually broken down into sort of 660
areas based apartment we really need to
try to dress up answers and they are
just can be very high level and now
things like how reactive integrity and
ethics have them hope and the
we look at that man in our economics
those objectives what inspections we do
create outcomes what are our
capabilities and how do we manage risk
we've got lots of stuff in Eric's is
detail report on things
bring them to ship country procedure
walls have combat in jars all these
percentages and so on and ultimately
what that does and this is all the work
that's been put it up from the internal
destruction armed factions team and also
from something called service assurance
local school students plan for us
especially they made questionnaire we go
absolute assistant director at once a
year where the serious questions that
they're so tell me how how many comes if
you've had a sizable sale any time
together cellphone rings do you think
you are that is that we covered for XY
then will that go back in these service
the opportunities like I will know there
are 30 weaknesses in their areas in
essence their governance and then that's
what it gets got to produce into this
reports that staff give your fears it's
not just intern opportune it's not just
my views one by one on my five things
new is actually the music to the
assistant directors as well securely
well okay we've got positive thing
that's the bulk of the report there's a
part of the end would send you to and I
say for some of the matters that were
raised in 2015-16 the answer that's been
taken and also the target for the plan
so again some of the actions that
they've taken last year
continuously taking in some of these
cases that we've reviewed the
Constitution leave that claim stood one
of the meeting 15 months ago
that's they all go in the second tranche
that is going on linked to this year
financial resilience he's raised pretty
much every year as at risk
and I'll be honest I think we like that
every year from where the next year to
his offseason those securities and
government and one is going to be
towards with a bit efficiencies there
and the restraint about the fact we
didn't have a keyboard executive
employed for the prior year we had last
year just on and also we have another
fourth fact we've raised or we're going
to create at the time a new trading arm
and as we gateway to another mind for
several months actually
and one thing that Chad come up again
now eat healthy lately I'm going to talk
about it again determine object or later
on there was a medication kind of help
in safety there wasn't the right people
placing another by support makes
apologize
we've now got a compensate with last
baby inflate this is lots of funny you
going on now have one evening a really
pushing slightly training thrown we've
got myself invited before focuses on the
council
going for win their war risk items that
we need to consider and none of these
will be known to your team all perish
before that I teach in migration we've
talked about this continuation of health
prospective I said financial resilience
will always be negative in English
finish and as we talked about as well
cause again can support was raised that
you know what we had in place was
include an app that's come out of the
peer review Cleveland couple years ago
and we've now got a council chaplain in
place and they're actually pushing for a
lot of property updates and refreshing
tons of spam
what would finally nasty a lot of it is
just it slightly out so far after years
there's not a lot of tips wrong with it
without an supports up it just needs a
bit of an update rules of the Impala
worked out with my cousin of morning
same slope see where we can stop that to
kids especially between ages
and so that's a report update easy
options or particular question touching
recommendation is much more critically a
police response you have some counsel to
the leader to say they have to really
government's arrange
so just avoid thank you so it is
importantly we're talking from a trip
them just accounted or think making
themselves are two separate I think they
are sort of ciliary body bless them
softly have the first point and I'm
sorry two libraries on takes like twenty
five talk about keeping a distinct like
start there and it goes on to say the
final sentence addition to utilizing
constituent programming recipient and
conversation kind treated that
situational driving patterns and
problems
naturally the muscle team collaboration
project analyzing absentee education
further back in the field
currently and
I have seen this report is mentioning
licensing sleep safe when we through
where it is public that in February that
ICT project was a great beginning the
regulations very profound in simply
collecting
I think the size of it
it seems to extent I need some what
I have more concerns with the aussies
protectively exosuit February these
report writing notes to know what this
report is going through that's we just
say that it's not whether the ICT
project passes or fails it's about the
fact that we are moving to a new IPC
cloud-based program it will mean with a
potential government wherever we move
these we further work on you that you
don't actually try to say that there is
an additional risk because the project
is often failing or the other thing is
more about assets back we are making
certain I think this is therefore the
government's ground that might have
become more columns and anything however
we have seen her yet
however imitation Lincoln with the ICT
con trick
and include something about sequence
enormous so in those words the say that
the national problems would Africa story
about instead of every trades and their
it's being taken next year that the ice
in my emotional needs over that is not a
football commission or not the core
purpose register which was not the means
March as an abalone
so this is not about an equal to that
the government's ranking to be having
lunch
so before we retire maggot immunity -
that's not the I press record so every
new in fact we don't build attacks on
civil versus water coolers in your mouth
and so this report is not necessarily
this is what we talked about leprosy or
power vacuums are seeking product like
this that's their number targets this is
all about the fact that
you don't want raging anyone
and gentlemen anything sensitive in
amateur famous
that's what amounted sir I know food
correction points it better as well
which my America very profound hides not
let's Emily first sentence insulting
departments developer license in
licensee at abilities other type
magnifique reading overheated appeals
and technical training over two years
so there this was difficult not even to
have another baby
Russell must be right there you know
implement its tricks Emma
we've set another plate
the page 1 point is something that
exceeds what once is that the medium
turbine stretch the MTFs that was
approved as a conservative business if
it wasn't we budget
yes a budget - presented essence arrived
and they're working on through p.m. -
survivor experience we just every day
together
there's never that you're going top of
one with nine we have the herbs first
join in second one presentation on ad
for everything to the promotion presence
that was a very trying to persecute
previously launched substitute it was a
policy
yeah
to get off the Texan invincible
to provide wigs opening so members
turned out so yeah
to the present given to important to the
RT there is an energy converts office I
waited to hear in these idle sugars both
are you that one - Jenny Burton this
might be more verbal 9.1 paragraphs and
cross passes men for investment both
employees
just about to
that's all get right Alexis impatient a
very good question
so quite - and then I was like wait
cuantos in the information reproduce of
obviously I'm able to done we have the
least expected elsewhere in the books
where we have a counter full champion
yet
we take a lot of Correspondence man now
I
set our very good
more than
then
the army is all best accident is a
testament to think agility work yourself
up as well as very clear about it just
about the council's depend on when one
for Perry brothel
the council's ICT network is meant by a
stone providing appropriate industry
standard cybersecurity measures are in
place
that Cougars that bag standard
on 12
it seems like it's a standard paragraph
I'm stuck in there just because in the
instinctive estimator and people more
cows imagine a so a year ago this
argument conservative action complaint
in a petition - it's very nice something
hasn't towards producing I am all
wrapped into them one is the adviser of
what we purchased from katasonych turn
pp in the street and whether that's good
enough or not that another question
Arcana but that's that's what we verges
we certainly have one hundred apartments
best part we need
what really issues that
question mark is that good enough that
certain enough problems
the house you might be
but
and
so
the question really lets offense will be
ensuring openness a comparative
psychology
taking the practice Pharisee reporting
capability to survive question that the
amount of cases literately private
confidential and are actually enabling
transparency and especially when they
actually go explain
becomes under quite a conception and I'm
just concerned too many odds against are
coming on there
omnomnom bankers
see we determine eligibility who might
want to I was influenced that likely
become a stem field there was a
something there that will seem that
one's relationship start a group of us
money knowledge that is public activity
who is said monitoring these principles
of
excellent decision
and that's okay
trust aside we are going to do processes
I suppose if we look back at do we have
a policy in front of them and that we
will publish everything we can emergence
of deep sleep
Mina Stokes a little book whether the
content of that without some question
without often becomes false objective
map
counselor
but especially my directing about how
safety
that's been taken from that important
could I get you spread the HR people
slide quietly Department out in a month
of sorts
second levels of the devoted resources
excelsis I'll be honest national
although they are now so we can patch
this was sorry for myself
[Music]
it was actually about 37% imagine
they'll only recopy
around five in june of last year's of
humans there are support and create
equality
disgust
the health services will eventually
language feature each entirely from a
half white and
the whole commercial
so what probably
the into second kind tsunami I think
that off-the-shelf
standard all the
remember Platinum's to answer is yo
clattering Windows 10 there's the only
fifty interior cloudy the smock so by
the
all educators out
without knocking
thank you someone
the recommendation is proposal resolves
that immensely 2016 15 and government
segment east side travel eager to
counsel and the metal director will bear
winds of all circles
by a certain degree Bertha
which was five of ten to the report of
the assistant director democratic
services which presents the updated
local gomers the total pool of
governments the members of roses
Caitlin
logan coefficients of a sense of place
mr. president I've got the code page
except our members not the main
principles of the government's District
Council and that is basically taking
good practice within the CalPERS
commitment of the center full of similar
federal governments and local government
the code is essentially a framework in
which the calculus accountable for its
users takeovers in the white community
it drives the way mature Council carried
out their functions through its members
and officers and the procedures and
processes for each of our matrix work
the turret courage ain't if that isn't
the same public confidence the bulk
standard document suggests they put in
place the local forest itself that
principle
good governments and what that lined up
like the water council
if we have invested and so this
mathematical something estimation
corpus placed aqua with mine
design
hopefully some comprehensives they are
going to proactively enjoy Roman culture
etc cetera think odd because actually
exempt us the focus will turn colourful
as opportunity we apparently audience
you know
the advocacy of dummy government's
happen I'm getting to the Getty revolt
two-month agree to put up on the
revolving critical reports of a
standardization and it seems time also
giving what we are here to make sure
this council the gears of sweetums
so my concerns are that perhaps that
yes we might
the answer is writing the article
council in introducing reportage you
might be exempt I know that
has to make some pass it will suddenly
start with
American director and release
for fusion the one point of exempt
results and I'm sure my college degree
at that point that we feel awful and
they should be able to institute the
early public we potentially slipped
meaningless going to accept physics to
the Lawrence I attempt our Tunes will be
heard later
intensely perhaps something has stopped
second Borden is loading position should
start to check to check out intellectual
counselors experiences
these motorcycles are it is another
concealment okay successful melted sexy
check now just follow from cows avoid it
and going back to my earlier point in
deterring culprits will be ensuring
hopefully supposed practice by Colin
engage one conservative a wall sort of
risk leprosy it because so many items
are exempt are we as a council
vulnerable perhaps if you have an
accusation that we haven't follow the
correct tendering process or services
provided
how can we have these children with
complaints outside are able to fit for
ICT complexity
any contract required it's awesome
anything that expanded the nature of
contract weathers matron hands up use
the framework in relation to the ICP
project issues they explained them my
foot brown services you can but many
tender it's like with the period frame
so in potentially explained to offer you
choose includes a favorite that makes it
up of other work for you in that all the
AG record requirements have been
unfaithful to you you can take assurance
that that by those receipts in place are
totally if you can go down period
enduring but all these powers from a
traumatic out swing are vulnerable to
any education we are cause we are mafia
European see these the term exempts are
than the determination of exemption it
is separate from the authority having to
make sure it follows correct tendering
procedures and you wouldn't expect any
report that happens to be defined as
exempt to be any less sort of
considering all the faculty needs
debating now it's just it's just very
commercial sensitivities that wouldn't
you might not want to provide the
figures that the composite tendered but
you wouldn't you wouldn't that exempt
wouldn't impact on on the tendering
requirements or or any of the
requirements
negative on the corporates problems
managing risks and performance subjects
for managing performance right on the
last item on 10:13 I'm not sure if this
is the forward for actually bringing
this up but he certainly has become a
concern that wine recently through being
involved in certain project on but a
negative act because this is more
effective the principle that I'm trying
to develop here ensuring there is
consistency between specification status
of such as budgets and post information
paper implementation reports
what was highlighted this to me is one
particular issue that I have been
involved in where when there were
figures and budgets representative
council for council for us to consider
making a decision I thought that some of
the figures that were actually presented
being in the relevant industry and I
made my reservations now and I was told
we set budgets now that we further down
the line and there has been a more
specific breakdown better if I'm related
as much as I possibly could to the
original budget it was probably around
about six and the price
now the question that I've got on this
is how much control is very based when
offices are producing reports - for
council on budgets
and what those budgets are based on is
obvious to me what has actually happened
in that particular case it is that there
was a budget that was put forward with
figures that were put forward to
actually make the case from what wanted
without substance
and there has been proven sins and I
questioned it the time and I was
so basically that we deal with them
now because we made the decision council
based on the budgets that we presented
to us I would suggest that that's giving
us bit of risk
either way and any financial report the
House Counsel Catman all did review mess
involve somebody sir
so I personally
on through and that means I have to do
tillage in fact inspection is my goal
make sure they respond very for money
that we apply to consider every best
possible your financial implication for
sports far as we can or we can't do that
predict the future so it will always be
things to come out they will always be
things that happen for what we can't
have is that your question in you
negative 1/5 one rock which is
ineffective
a lot of young Ivanka my name's will
report 1.1 in organizations with their
names that people what they say the rest
of their ability they are providing a
and external clients you to say allow a
lot or I do more powerless innovation
something quality or anywhere else
we're closing in still sore
laughing New Zealand is a group attempts
misleading but when I questioned it
originally I was told don't worry
DeLuise up there further down the line
now because it was just the ticket was
picked out but she put something into
puzzles now I question get to the top
because also like my professional
impression subs that I now we are
talking about ones particular odds if
you want me to take available use or out
your I was going to thank you very much
our peppers are quite specific issue of
Rudovsky
it's highlighted an issue not
particular project that he's going
through is not the issue the issue for
me is that if we question some of these
projects that are cookie and he sponsor
do due diligence on this oh now I don't
question your professional abilities
you're not involved in industry hon
thank you so I would expect the you to
get recommendation from the offices to
say that this is the correct thing but
they're not the YouTube to check the
what does anyone - to check the figures
that are put into budgets and first
place I understand the battle create a
huge workload and I understand that
these things been slipped through we
must have some sort of local instance in
my case where I questioned these issues
at the time new counselor in the
but they watch seeds there was a
behavior
and also biggest issue and so I had to
let you go
so is there something in place or are
you saying well if they is the basic
reporter question because you come to
read to you so the couple of things
first of all tells a specific question
on a report that canceling
I really should write every 1% a preset
that gives us a chance a chance the
personal that's the best one thing you
know we get quite detailed questions in
our meetings very difficult for us
talking people and so that would be
person if you feel person cancel
interesting problem difficulties wishing
something so divide state models without
one more than happy talk to you about it
and after that if you'd like coming up
we are hoping on you can often
that's ugly something I find it on
yeah that's what we can't have is a
nicer what felt like an accusation that
things are going wrong when actually
less the first are perfectly so that's
rather have that bhai sir there's not
the surface of quiet for you at least do
not expect as being said but all in a
minute currently without a pro/con
cyclomatic we can give you a full answer
about lensing we are in terms of any now
at the glance reports there are going to
obviously be elements vestments of
course but I would expect that I've
certainly done expected if I professor
this in the directors I produced a
report that they've got thinking that
now so we will go back they were devoted
from local customs of archives with that
there's a logical test to a see or
they're doing and then might've
reasonable assumptions in the documents
of consumption at the point that they'd
actually that looks as good in disguise
thing we're not now the restaurants and
things will move rapidly as long as
there's something there but it's not
within
clock design theater in psychics I think
is probably always produced bout time
you also might not that outside so these
from said
or any other questions
of the relations of the results and
determine fingerprints of every justice
but we never consider the report of
these directors democratic services
summarizing the proposed recommendations
the original 70 paste
a planetoid accentuated the schedule
Christmas for the cook down here just
gives you
like an idea which we'd like to see over
nexi months
the recommendation is a dis proposal
which resolves additional business for
the audit committee a 1788 we noted
surgery doctors
lesson four update okay the safety risks
3a and 3b and equipment was Webster only
again so not to mention so like identity
the risk register are being back in
March and it was a piece in there there
was a certain risk in there which was
around children safety and it had a red
radish green flag back to the father
mentor wife when I went on to explain
that actually walks park that was there
two very distinct element in there one
was around it was super food where we
food environmental risk and also being
combined with that Ward Health and
Safety and where I'll try to explain
that as in previous you take these where
we have quite fleet right now brought
food standards wishes with that that's a
lot better what else in sight you'd
actually got worse are three things like
that's the reason of the risk its back
rent we have a conversation about it as
you said that we really need just
quickly that to riskier very
specifically avoided helps out the item
and then what is the suicide attempt and
that's what this report is do it
ineffective judge effects or meant in
the risk register now to slit wrists are
three to three items which in a very
brief update on where we actually are
with in terms of controls and as you can
see that the winner insist reasonably do
it for some of a health and safety both
pollen work that started and ongoing I'm
sorry with the Food Standards part where
we still got some quite poor generally
control which doesn't help society and
that's where it matters to persons
before our last year with lots of light
lots of positive Latin action as require
rapid turnaround
so it's just a bit of an update to move
or progressed when's the next time
you'll see a 3 a.m. in three weeks
we need successes
very much the recomment religiously
local just sub one question and it's an
use come up since he talking about in
the county we go and inspect the
premises and give them a
right what is the risk because I think
those implicates are all mentioned
of premises getting a one-star rating
and actually putting entire solid
to be given somewhere
more unsure
what I said people somewhere has been
given a one-star rating and they'll
display five star rating
I think I think we come back to members
Alexis interesting question okay yeah
well being Iranian to find out the most
are
following on from Casselton
how often are checks made hopefully
we depended on the risk
only in certain Scott stickers and their
535 in something keep going around
checking that occasion yes as we like to
commend us on the more perhaps critical
question we'll let that one as well
that's room service clarify that's what
so it's not very high sort of on top of
you perfecting houses the recommended
recommendation is is compose the velvety
resolved that the content of the culprit
was register which 3a are a baby notes
is a degrees Kelvin well that concludes
the business Thank You officers